about this time I saw a great still life
exhibit by the Dutch masters of the
periods late 1600s and I was blown away
that these things looked as fresh now as
they did then and I was got really
interested in that idea this was a
little side piece I had going on you
know 20 or some paintings I've never
shown anybody they were all endangered
plants and animals and I had a MIDI
pattern or a handprint
so to me they were represented sort of
the hand of man which took away their
chance of surviving in the hand of man
that was also trying to keep it just to
survive allow it to survive and that
sort of led indirectly into this whole
series I did in about the mid 90s I
guess that was called nature in the
margins so it was my local environment
where something was surviving in this
little pocket that was undisturbed you
know it's just too cold and gave transit
bus going by but you know things just
will survive if they have enough room
and it also gave me this incredible
opportunity to go through lots and lots
of trying out of materials of mediums of
pigments and that's how I find about
mummy Brown so people used to actually
grind up mummy brains to make a color
that's roughly that color maybe a little
more brown in my monitor it's a little
more Brown it wasn't a very good pigment
it got very expensive so people started
grinding up any old mummy a cat or bones
or whatever and it was also called ke
patte mortem which means dead head weird
we've now have much better colors that
are much more permanent but you know
Indian yellow was made out of cow dung
that marigold petals were their only
food coach Anil is the squished up scale
bugs that grow in cactus and we still
use that as a number one red dye and
lipsticks and whatnot and there's lots
of those so what I was interested in was
the difference between a fugitive color
that will not last and a pigment that is
pure enough and stable enough that will
last for an unknown
amount of time so I was at some of at
least one of those early long now
meetings trying to build models as ideas
were flowing around about how a library
might look and so I was already thinking
and kind of a parallel track about
permanence about how to make something
that might be worth a that might last
and be some sort of statement there
might be worth lasting having lasts and
and about ninety-eight I got a mailer
from the Sierra Club it was the hundred
most endangered animals in the United
States and this serve aha moment you
know that you have I said like I'm gonna
make a Dutch still life fading which you
know if I heard myself I would have
thought wait a minute are you crazy but
I just decided to try it and this was
the result at the time I didn't have any
real credentials in science I went to
five universities I think and these were
the in date this was the list of the
endangered things that I could get
access to so it's it's a very odd
collection of things
[Music]